[Musique]
la télévision est la plus grande
victoire de l'image les maisons du monde
entier se sont couvertes d'antenne elles
seront bientôt 200 millions c'est anthem
semblant surgir des toits soul ondes qui
désert aux l'image
[Musique]
l'image de l'événement immédiate des
fidèles ou presque puisqu'il leur
manquait ce facteur de vérité
essentielle la couleur le monde vivant
est en couleur et son image ne peut être
condamné au noir et blanc mais pour
diffuser aujourd'hui une image en
couleur il faut penser aux centaines de
millions de téléspectateurs qui ne
peuvent recevoir qu'en noir et blanc et
qu'il serait injuste de sacrifier ainsi
le programme en couleurs telles que leur
soient les téléspectateurs munis d'un
téléviseur couleur le téléspectateur
plastique équipé du loiret blanc doit
pouvoir le capter c'est la première
compatibilité imposé à la télévision en
couleurs quand le programme n'est
transmis conte noir et blanc on ne
souhaite obliger le téléspectateur muni
du téléviseur couleur d'allumer un
téléviseur noir et blanc classique pour
le recevoir
il faut donc que le téléviseur couleur
reçoivent aussi le noir et blanc c'est
la deuxième compatibilité la télévision
en couleurs soumise ces impératifs va se
servir des méthodes du noir et blanc
comment fallait il faire pour sauver
pour prévenir la rage c'est le tube
analyseur de la caméra traduit d'abord
l'image formé sur la cible
photoélectrique en une réplique de la
scène visée cette réplique formé de
chaque électeur correspond point par
point à l'intensité lumineuse de la
scène et c'est point par point qu'elle
va être démontée par le faisceau
d'électrons analyseur recueillant
successivement les charges électriques
comme si le démonter un mur brique par
brique al'allure records il est vrai de
6 millions de briques par seconde ainsi
se forment le signal vidéo donnant à
chaque instant la valeur lumineuse d'un
point d'image quand il est transmis par
radio
c'est la télévision
pour reconstruire l'image de la rizerie
chacune deux points étaient dictés par
une impulsion repères de ligne qui
synchronise le balayage du tube
cathodique de réception où l'image se
reconstitue toujours quand en plus grand
sera le nombre de points par ligne plus
film sera l'image c'est la définition
horizontale le nombre de lignes de
balayage 625 par exemple caractérise la
définition verticale de l'image la
télévision est au service de l'humain
qui s'accommode admirablement de ces
procédés il fusionne tous les points en
une image unique
comme au cinéma la succession rapide
d'image du mobile lui donne l'impression
du mouvement une bonne nouvelle pour les
automobilistes mais c'est être humain
est en couleur lui aussi
les conneries mais triste savent depuis
longtemps analyser la structure des
couleurs et le physicien maxwell en a
décrit les lois de façon intuitive avec
son triangle découverts chaque point de
couleur située à l'intérieur de ce
triangle née d'une addition à doses
variables des couleurs primaires rouge
bleu vert au centre du triangle un
mélange additifs ados égal de rouge de
bleu et de vert donne le blanc de
référence la position d'un point par
rapport au sommet du triangle figure la
dose des primaires ainsi un point
turquoise comporte beaucoup de bleu
[Musique]
presqu'autant de verre est très peu de
vous
un point jaune sera produit par du bouge
pas mal de revers et du bleu à très
faible dose
[Musique]
ces primaires constitutive a plus ou
moins hautes doses peuvent engendrer un
signal électrique proportionnelle dans
trois caméras qui seraient spécialisées
chacune dans une telle primaire la rouge
la bleue et la verte l'ensemble des
trois signaux électriques définissent
conjointement le point de couleur si ce
point de couleur se déplace dans le
triangle les signaux électriques vous
variez non pas indépendamment l'un de
l'autre mais suivant la loi même de la
trichromie la conservation des écarts
entre les trois signaux est donc
essentiel pour la reproduction des
couleurs pour transmettre les images en
couleur
la première idée consiste ainsi à
braquer sur la scène à télévisée trois
caméras identique chacune muni de son
filtre le rouge le bleu et le vert
chaque caméra analyse alors à pleine
définition les images existant dans les
trois couleurs primaires traités comme
des images indépendantes chacune ayant
sa brillance propres
[Musique]
les signaux vidéo ignorent qu'ils
correspondent à une couleur particulière
ils peuvent attaquer trois tubes
récepteur qui projette l'image coloré
fidèles obtenus par synthèse additive
[Musique]
la ville de procéder de réception
encombrants est délicat mais en fait
valable que pour de grands écrans
professionnels et n'a pas sa place dans
le récepteur individuelles qui exige un
tube unique
le col de ce tube unique comporte trois
canons électrons dont chacun sera mis au
service d'une couleur il n'est
évidemment pas question de superposer
simplement les écrans colorées ses
écrans ont alors été fragmentée en de
multiples points colorés verts bleus
rouges juxtaposée à l'intérieur du tube
sur sa face interne
ces points colorés son décor
luminescents réagissant dans leur
couleur spécifique aux chocs des
électrons on les appelle des phosphores
ils sont regroupés en bouquet de 3 et
l'écran comporte près d'un demi million
à distance normal ces points se fondent
ensemble pour donner une impression
continue quand l'excitation des trois
phosphore du bouquet est égal
cette impression est celle du blanc
quand les canons vert et bleu sont et à
la plage et rouge ou verte
si les canons rouge et bleu sont coupées
pour assurer cette excitation sélective
par les canons les inventeurs américains
de ce tube universellement adoptées ont
engagé news mans disposer un masque
perforé entre les canons et les camps
masque perforé d'autant de trous qu'il
ya deux bouquets ainsi le canon affecté
au rouge le pour attirer ces électrons à
travers le trou qu'en faisant mouche sur
le phosphore rouge
de même pour le bleu et le vert
[Musique]
l'image est reconstituée en permanence
par le balayage des bouquets ligne après
ligne
la dose exacte d'excitation des
phosphores est réglé à tout instant par
le signal primaire qui commandent
l'intensité du feu d'électrons de chaque
camion dans sa couleur
en fait ces canons sont constitués d'une
cathode émettant les électrons et
d'organes de contrôle les mails
interposés sur leur trajet c est même
présente office de ram modère le débit
des électrons suivant le signal
électrique quand le rapliq
tel est le tube prix canon à masquer qui
reconstitue l'image couleurs mais
comment assurer la compatibilité à
partir de l'un des signaux électriques
primaire aucun ne convient en réalité
pour former l'image noir et blanc sur un
tube classique monochrome
on ne rendrai parfaitement compte de
l'intensité lumineuse du sujet ni par le
signal rouge ni par le bleu ni par le
vert il faut autre chose il faut
l'information de luminance quand le flux
de lumière est important leblanc et
brillant quand ils diminuent les
couleurs s'assombrissent le blanc
rejoint le noir en passant par la gamme
des gris a besoin de couleurs subissant
ces variations fera paris les signaux
électriques mais ils varieront tous les
trois proportionnellement aux
changements d'intensité
2 il existe donc un signal commun aux
trois caméras ce signal commun va
pouvoir être 10 juin des signaux
primaire propres à chacune des caméras
il définit l'intensité lumineuse de la
scène colorée et porte ainsi en lui une
information de toute première importance
l'information de luminance qui a
plusieurs rôles à jouer à partir des
trois signaux primaire l'élaboration du
signal de luminance désigné par le
symbole y demande un peu d'arithmétique
la simple addition des trois primaires
seraient maladroite car la réponse de la
rétine au flux coloré et aime que c'est
la lumière dans le vert qui apporte au
cerveau l'impression subjective maximum
celle du rouge
une impression moyenne celle du bleu
enfin une impression faible le signal
électrique de luminance et donc mieux
donné par la somme pondérée de signaux
primaire dont les coefficients
traduisent les fait subjectif réel la
somme de ses coefficients est égal à
l'unité ce signal de luminance dès lors
parfaitement analogue au signal de la
télévision classique en noir et blanc
pour après viennent alimenter un
récepteur mans et blanc
[Musique]
voilà maintenant respecter la première
loi de compatibilité grâce à ce signal
de luminance élaboré à partir des signes
aux primaires mais à côté de ce premier
rôle le signal de luminance y en tient
un autre fondamental dans la
transmission de l'image en couleurs ce
rôle est celui d'un pilote d'un
garde-fou qui indique à chaque instant
récepteur la somme des trois primaires
ne pas dépasser pour ne pas fausser par
rapport à la scène originale la quantité
de lumière fournie aux téléspectateurs
[Musique]
comptable qui veillent en permanence à
la fidélité de l'addition le signal de
luminance va permettre de réaliser une
première économie puisque le signal de
luminance porte une dose connue de
chacun des signes aux primaires il
serait superflu de transmettre
simultanément récepteur les trois signes
aux primaires si on renonce avance m le
signal primaire verts par exemple le
récepteur ne recevra naturellement
aucune information directe dans le cher
[Musique]
en revanche si du signal de luminance y
il soustrait après les avoir pondérer
les signaux rouges et bleus qu'il reçoit
en permanence le récepteur sera
reconstitué le signal vers manquant les
trois signaux primaires sont ainsi tous
obtenu est prêt à attaquer le tube
ce calcul électronique s'opère la
réception de façon continue dans une
matrice et le signal vers soeur en
permanence trois signaux celui de
luminance et ceux de couleur sont donc
transmis mais affecté trois émetteurs
distincts chacun serait parfaitement
impraticable l'espace radioélectrique
déjà forte encombrer la mettrait pas un
tel gaspillage de fréquences d'autres
économies sur le contenu des signaux
sont heureusement possible car l'oeil et
de connivence avec ingénieurs l'oeil
ignore en effet la couleur des détails
très faim dont il ne perçoit plus que
l'intensité lumineuse les nuances exacte
de ses trois fils bleus par exemple
n'apparaîtrait vraiment à l'oeil que sur
de grandes surfaces
or ce qui échappe à la vision naturelle
il serait vain de chercher à le
transmettre les détails très fin c'est
au signal de luminance élaboré à partir
des primaires à haute définition
fournies par les caméras qu'incombe
leurs transmissions les signaux
primaires seront donc soulagé de cette
mission d'information le signal de
luminance y est soustrait du signal
rouge et aussi du signal bleus opération
qui donne naissance à deux signaux dit
de chrominance la réduction de la
finesse des analyses de la chrominance
se traduit par la possibilité de
comprimés
à l'aide de filtres au départ la bande
de fréquence que tout signal emprunte au
spectre radioélectrique autour de sa
fréquence porteuse les lois de
l'information sont en effet inexorable
plus l'image est fouillé plus large et
la bande de fréquence que nécessite
cette transmission correct c'est le prix
à payer dans l'espace radioélectrique
avec sa haute définition
l'imac luminance est largement servi par
une transmission à large bande
l'image de chrominance se satisfait
d'une définition plus basse on se trouve
toujours à la tête de trois signaux
qu'il s'agit de transmettre sur
l'émetteur unique
la technique téléphonique éprouvé des
fréquences sous-porteuse va résoudre ce
problème apparemment insoluble
grâce au fait que les deux signaux de
chrominance peuvent se transmettre avant
de ré duit articulé sur leur fréquence
porteuse
ces bandes réduite sont encastrées dans
la bande de grandes largeurs consacré à
la luminance à pleine définition
les fréquences porteuse de chrominance
seront regardés par la porte principale
comme partie intégrante du signal de
luminance d'où leur nom de sous porteuse
des filtrages soigner à l'arrivée comme
au départ empêcheront toute confusion
un peu comme les voies d'un coeur fondu
dans un ensemble vocal unique gardent
leur fréquence propre facilement
identifiables les soprani chante la
couleur l'ensemble le noir et blanc
dessous porteuses sont semble-t-il
nécessaire mais l'électronique qu'on
ferait encore des ressources et une
seule sous porteuse peut suffire ont
pris il est vrai d'une double modulation
simultanée de cette unique sous porteuse
par les deux signaux de chrominance les
signaux complexe de la télévision en
couleurs rayonné par un seul émetteur
sont reçus ensemble par le récepteur
réglé sur la fréquence est mise à la
sortie les divers circuit
d'amplification filtrage détection le
signal de luminance et les deux signaux
de chrominance rouge et bleu se retrouve
à l'entrée d'une matrice qui fournira
les trois signaux primaire dont le vert
une simple addition de la communance
rouge et de la luminance à haute
définition restitue le signal-prix mer
rouge
de même pour le signal primaires bleu le
vert exige au préalable le calcul de la
communance verte à partir des trois
signaux reçus
ces additions de luminance injecte en
permanence une haute définition aux
primaires non plus celle qu'il possédait
emploie maintenant perdu par compression
mais cette haute définition collective
portée par le signal de luminance ces
opérations peuvent être transféré en
grande partie dans les canons du tube
les signaux de chrominance rouge et bleu
sont envoyés directement sur les canes
ont affecté à leurs couleurs
la matrice se borne à élaborer le signal
de chrominance du verre celui qui n'est
pas transmis le signal de luminance
attaque les cas top des trois canons
ollier ensemble les faisceaux
d'électrons suivre l'intensité du signal
de luminance tous ensemble avec la
pleine définition porté par celui ci le
signal de chrominance appliquée aux vnf
module le faisceau la résultante finale
et son intensité sont bien conformes
signa le primaire
[Musique]
quand il n'y a pas de couleur du tout
dans l'image comme dans cette robe les
signaux de chrominance un nul ce qui
n'est pas leur moindre avantage pour le
vérifier encore un peu d'arithmétique
et même dans le chèvre le signal de
luminance seule commande les trophées
sont tous ensemble les trois phosphore
sont excités pareillement ils
reproduisent bien du gris
la réapparition de couleur au sein de
l'image déséquilibre ce tir égaliser en
ajoutant l'information de chrominance
l'image couleurs se nourrit de luminance
et de chrominance émis en télévision
classique
ce bouquet deviendra gris le tube du
téléviseur couleur ne reçoit plus
maintenant qu'un signal vidéo classique
pour alimenter ces trois canons c'est la
deuxième compatibilité les indéniables
qualités de ces images ne doivent pas
masquer les difficultés et les risques
qu'il y à transmettre deux informations
aussi délicate que la couleur quand
elles se partagent la voix unique d'une
seule sous porteuse d'un stabilité est
essentielle
il fallait explorer d'autres solutions
le système proposé pour le rend fier
d'attaché
ce système transmettent en un instant
donné un seul signal de chrominance par
exemple celui du bleu on voit qu'en
possession de cet unique signal bleus la
matrice ne pourrez calculer les deux
autres signaux de chrominance en rouge
et en verre elle ne connaît que leur
somme grâce au signal de luminance mais
à la réception
ce signal unique bleus est dédoublé en
deux jumeaux dont l'un se dirigera
directement vers la matrice tandis que
l'autre représenté au dessous renversera
un dispositif à retardement sortes de
handicaps qui lui fera subir un retard
d'une longueur soit le temps exact de
balayage d'une ligne à la prochaine
ligne on émettra un signal rouge qui à
la réception subira le même traitement
dédoublement puis dispositif en retard
pour l'un des jumeaux et ainsi de suite
bien sûr ce qu'on voit là au ralenti
avec des temps d'arrêt se déroule en
réalité de façon ininterrompue à la
cadence de plus de 15000 ligne la
seconde
que se passe-t-il à chaque instant à la
sortie de cette double voie
à chaque instant un signal bleu et un
signal rouge sont présents mais alors
que le signal bleus n'ayant subi aucun
retard est bien celui de la ligne en
cours de transmission le signal rouge
est un signal retardé emprunté à la
ligne précédente
ce sera l'un verse pour la ligne
suivante signal rouge normalement
transmis signal bleus emprunter la ligne
précédent il ne reste plus qu à
aiguiller tous les signaux de même
couleur vers l'entrée correspondant
c'est le rôle de l'inverser électronique
automatiquement déclenchée par les
impulsions de balayage ainsi ligne après
ligne
le processus se répète et l'image se
reconstitue tel est le principe du
balayage alternée l'une des bases du
nouveau procédé du procédé proposé pour
l'europe le ccap
[Musique]
ce balayage alterné exploitant deux fois
sur deux lignes voisine une même
information de chrominance entraîne une
baisse de la définition verticale mais
cette définition verticale est toujours
très largement supérieur à ce que leur
demande
sa réduction entame à peine la marge
énorme par rapport à la définition
horizontale transmise à bandes réduite
une image parfaite
et pourtant un seul signal de
chrominance à transmettre à la fois avec
cet atout techniques considérables
le système ccam a pu choisir pour la
sous porteuse de comines ans et son
signal unique le meilleur procédé de
transmission
la modulation de fréquence celle de la
haute fidélité en modulation de
fréquence londe supportant le signal
conserve une amplitude rigoureusement
constants le signal de la modifie pas la
fréquence de la sous porteuse
caractérise le blanc de référence les
fréquences qui s'en écartent caractérise
les autres points de couleur les signaux
primaire issus de la caméra rouge par
exemple module la fréquence de référence
suivant la dose de primaires rouge
un point se déplaçant vers le turquoise
correspondra à une augmentation de
fréquence une fréquence supérieure la
fréquence de référence caractérise donc
le turquoise
inversement en se déplaçant vers le
sommet rouge
la fréquence caractéristiques diminue en
passant par la fréquence de référence du
blanc ainsi la modulation de fréquence
rend elle compte de la position exacte
des points de couleur incluse dans sa
modulation de fréquence la chrominance
du secam est prêt à affronter les
péripéties de la transmission
c'est un signal robuste il y a dans la
théorie de l'information une loi
physique qui tend à désorganiser tout
message à le noyer dans le bruit de fond
général du monde électro magnétique
qu'il traverse comme dans ses ennemis
plus proche que sont les parasites
industriels
mais la communance elle-même constituée
à un certain degré un signal parasites
pour l'image de luminance reçu par les
téléviseurs noir et blanc et c'est
encore la modulation de fréquence avec
son amplitude rigoureusement constante
bien en dessous de l'amplitude de
luminance qui offre la protection la
meilleure contre cet effet parasites
cette modulation apporte encore d'autres
avantages
les altérations que subit la phase
calage autant 02 tous phénomènes
vibratoires modifie le phénomène si
l'information est liée à la phase elle
en subira les fluctuations en modulation
fréquents
l'information est contenue dans le
nombre d'oscillations contée par le
récepteur donc l'information de tintin
dans le secam ne sera pas affectée
normalement par les altérations de
phases qualités fondamentales qui permet
au signal de franchir correctement les
longues lignes de transmission des
relais aux émetteurs en passant par les
faisceaux hertziens
au studio même cette qualité permettent
aux ccam d'enregistrer ces signaux sur
les magnétoscopes classique du noir et
blanc nouvel avantage au moment où
l'enregistrement magnétique des
programmes de télévision s'affirme comme
l'un des meilleurs outils des
réalisateurs en bout de chaîne le
téléspectateur est le grand bénéficiaire
de toutes ces améliorations il ne
trouvera pas sur son téléviseur couleur
davantage de boutons à régler que sur le
téléviseur noir et blanc la tête
transmises rigoureusement par la
modulation fréquence n'a pas à être
réajusté l'image l'image en couleurs
émergents de signaux fidèles et stable
apportera l'authenticité du monde réel
ce monde est en couleurs et son image ne
pouvait vraiment pas être condamné au
noir et blanc
[Musique]